So, das müsste jetzt besser sein, das müsste jetzt besser aussehen.
So und jetzt machen wir das erste, was jeder gute Spieler immer macht, die Grafik runterstellen.
Textur Resolution ist ok, Particle Quality ist auch ok, Bullet Impact ist auch ok.
Haben die nicht so einen Overall Graphics Settings?
Shadow Map braucht kein Mensch.
Particle Lighting reicht mir ehrlich gesagt auch normal.
Pilmic SM.
Gut Anti Elates an meiner Grafikkarte liegt es nicht wirklich, da kann es sein, dass
ich mir sehr wenig einstellen kann.
Ich kann nur die Textur Qualität einstellen.
FPS größer Grafiker selbstverständlich, da wird mir der E-AX bestimmt zustimmen oder?
In Multiplayer spielen, FPS größer Grafik.
Das macht nur fette Anti Elasings, also richtiges Multi Sampling sollte keine Schlieren machen.
Keine Ahnung, was Filmatic, wir machen es mal auf, aber meiner Grafikkarte liegt es nicht.
1080 Ti habe ich drin.
Ok, gucken wir mal wie es läuft.
Auch keiner, kein Testation, da sieht man nur Gegner schlechter.
Bullet Impact ist gut, Particle Quality ist gut, Textur Resolution lassen wir auf jeden
Fall an.
AAF, das brauchen wir, da sieht man die Gegner besser oder zumindest sieht es über Range
ordentlicher aus.
Die Grafikkartensachen, die sollten bei mir nicht wirklich viel Auswirkung haben.
Dass sie Bildchen daneben haben, ja das finde ich auch gut.
Während das sucht, mal schauen, wie viel Platz habe ich noch auf meiner Platte.
Ach du Scheiße, wie soll ich denn da was aufnehmen?
Wie soll ich denn da was aufnehmen?
Ok Videos, ok ich habe bestimmt ein paar Olle Witze, die ich löschen kann.
Was ist das, ok das sind irgendwelche OBS Aufnahmen, weisen wir weg, Desktop braucht
keiner, Captures, Captures, auf gehts, 1080, 810p48, das ist neues Meta, iih Claymores,
was habe ich da drinnen, Claymores, aber es pixelt jetzt nicht so oder?
Es sollte jetzt eine ganze Ecke weniger pixeln, übrigens die Map geht mir immer noch auf
den Kicks, weil ich keine Ahnung habe wo da was abgeht.
Genau so wie vorher, das kann nicht sein, das sieht jetzt schon besser, na gut ich kann
mit, ehrlich gesagt Leute mit 4mbit kann ich nicht mehr machen, mit 4mbit kann ich nicht
mehr machen.
Das sieht übrigens kacke aus ohne Anti-Elasing, was ist eigentlich der Unterschied zwischen,
mit Anti-Elasing siehts besser aus, ich glaube da hat es gar nicht eingeschaltet jetzt oder?
Oh Wallbang geht nicht, no wallbang, gehen wir dem, wir machen jetzt den krassen Camper
Dude hier drinnen, komm her, kommst du her, kommst du her, der will nicht, ok wir machen
doch nicht den geilen Camper Dude, ich kann das nicht, ich kann so gerne sich campen,
ich kriege da Anfälle bei, war da ein Gegner, war da was eben gerade auf dem, war da gerade
was auf dem Dach oder, war da was auf dem Dach eben gerade, sah doch so aus, ich sah
doch auf dem Dach gerannt, ihr Leute, bester Spot, die kommen garantiert von da, keinweise
mit das, die war versackt auf Range, vor allem mit dem Schalldämpfer, ok Leute wir müssen
jetzt mal ran
ich höre übrigens laufen um mich drum herum noch Gegner, Alter diese Map, diese Map
macht mich fertig, gibt's nicht ey, jetzt hole ich die Kackkiste raus, Idiot hier, Zauns
und Bills sind asynchron, the fuck, wie soll das überhaupt gehen, wie soll das gehen,
da gibt's doch nicht mal eine Einstellung für, da gibt's doch nicht mal eine Einstellung
für, dass das asynchron sein könnte, gefrescht mal Leute, also ich hab keine Ahnung, es kann
nicht asynchron sein, ich hab nichts verzögert irgendwie hier, guckt mal, wir probieren jetzt
mal was, ja, so, vielleicht soll ich, was mir echt auf den Keks geht, was mir richtig
auf den Keks geht, das hier nicht merkt, hier, da ist nächstes Mal Asynchron, übrigens
wir können, vielleicht mach ich doch einen, vielleicht mach ich doch einen Update, einen
Grafikkarten Update, vielleicht bringt das was für die Performance, weil mehr FPS, man
kann nie genug FPS haben, nie genug FPS, hat er sich die Settings jetzt gemerkt, hoffentlich,
ja hat sich die Settings, hat sich die Settings nur halb gemerkt, hat sich die Settings irgendwie
nur halb gemerkt, ok, jetzt ist das Nutt auf einmal strikt, ok, was auch immer, wir spielen
jetzt einfach, eben war es noch moderat, also ich muss sagen, die defaultsense mit 800 DPI
fühlt sich ganz ok an, Domination, bin ich auf so einem Server gelandet eben, eben an
10 Millisekunden, wir müssen da oben drauf Leute, bester Spot, ok, oh in der Luft kann
man aussterben, Asynchron, warum ist das Asynchron, woher, woher soll das ein Delay geben, ich
hab kein Delay, OBS nimmt nicht mit Relay auf, wartet mal, Schuss, ernsthaft, wo soll
das herkommen, ok, das kommt jetzt echt schon mal voll auf den Sack, das hat, das Problem
hat kein Game, aber Kott irgendwie, ok, was soll ich da machen, was ist denn zu spät
Leute, der Sound oder das Bild, der Sound ist zu spät, ich hör mir das jetzt mal in
der Vorschau an, tatsächlich, fuck, das hat echt ein Delay, warum hat das ein Delay,
das kann man, das kann man doch nicht mal einstellen, ok, wenn das Sound ein Delay hat, was soll
ich denn da machen, ich kann ja schlecht Minus machen, ich kann dem Sound ein Delay geben,
aber wenn der Sound doch schon zu spät ist, wenn der Sound doch schon zu spät ist, bringt
mir das doch auch ein Delay auf den Sound nicht, dann ist ja der Sound noch später,
ja, negativer Delay ist Schwachsinn, das geht nicht, das kann man zwar einstellen,
aber das ergibt keinen Sinn, pass mal auf, jetzt hab ich negativer Delay, das ist kein
Unterschied, das geht, doch das geht, das ist besser jetzt oder, the fuck, wie zum Teufel
soll technisch negativer Delay überhaupt funktionieren, ey kotz, was ist das wieder,
ok, jetzt haben wir natürlich die Erste, was war das, bin gespottet, ok, schön, wenn
ich gespottet bin, kein Problem, easy spot, easy life, ist schon ein VTOL am Start, ey,
das Game, rein, settings gefixt, VTOL am Start, VTOL ist übelst OP, nur mal so angemerkt,
VTOL ist übelst OP, ach super, der nächste am Start, negativer Delay, wie soll denn sowas
überhaupt funktionieren, das ergibt null Sinn, egal, da gibt's halt keinen Sinn, auch
nicht, kacke, kacke, glitch spot hier, hallo, hallo, einer da, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
einer da, glitch ein, von hinten, jawoll, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ok, jawoll, oh, ich seh nix, fuck, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok
Oh
Will mich hinlegen, geht aber nicht
Achtung, Fall fährt, Fall fährt Play
Nein, nicht runterfallen
Okay, das ist ganz gut, dass man die nicht sieht von hier
Und wenn ich hab Scavenger bei?
Ich hab sonst nie Scavenger bei
Fuck, ich hab mich hier gekotcht
Denied
Alter, leg dich hin
Ach, das ist meiner
Ich hör von der Seite
Du hast nen Code und kannst nicht spielen
Das Problem hat ich auch
Du musst in deine Mails gucken
Dann hast du nochmal nen Code
Dann hast du nochmal nen Code am Start
Und mit dem Code kannst du dann was machen
Das ist meine Vorschau kaputt
Ich muss mal refreshen
Wie die immer wissen, dass da einer am Start ist
Hier ist es definitiv angenehmer als auf der PS4
Woher kommt der Code von der E-Mail? Keine Ahnung
Vielleicht irgendwas mit Fall of Duty oder irgendwas mit Activision
Alter, die sind immer da, wo man nicht hinguckt
Voll banged
Was war das denn?
Hast du seit B01 schon wieder mit Sana gezogen?
Ich hab mit dem noch nie gespielt
Weiß gar nicht, wo das herkommt
wir haben auch nie was zusammen aufgenommen
ich hab mal ein video von ihm gezeigt
der hat mal ein video von mir gezeigt
das ist alles
jaa
habt ihr gesehen wie schnell der sich umdrehen konnte
ist klar
erstmal gefangen
sehr fairer spawn
sehr fairer spawn gerade
what the fuck
könntest du mal ein tweet nach der runde abschenken
kann ich warn
also passt jetzt alles
vielleicht schaffen wir es dann die nächste runde
machen wir einfach bis ende zu spielen
ohne irgendwelchen mist
was hast du getweetet
zeig mal her
hast du geantwortet auf irgendwas
ich bin da nicht eingeloggt hier
was
ernsthaft jetzt
ok ich gucke auf den anderen rechner
ich seh von dir kein tweet
ist nix
Fredo ist der letzte der getweetet hat
kann man links rein posten
was willst du denn für link posten
ach so
ich wollte links hier umstellen
weil das ding sackt
und das
wie toll chat
besser
besser als jopper
wird es deine mein nachher neues windows nach windows 10 geben
bestimmt
ich glaube nicht
dass die windows
dass die ewig dieses windows service
geschiss machen also das werden die schon lange machen
aber dann irgendwann mit einer neuen version
oder aber
die benennen das um
diese jumps
nackt das war ein neuer sir
der typ ist down
was
windows
ach das sind flashes ich hab gar keine stunts dabei
richtig
keine stunts
bei
topkollege soll nicht
nope
cruise missile
geht ab hier
ich hab gesehen man kann die tür backen
man kann die tür backen und dann so hier durchgucken
ich will aus das dach hoch
das dach ist op
fuck
oh wir haben denn wie toll am start
es geht ab hier
fuck falsche richtung
ich dachte die spawnen jetzt da hinten
wieder mini delayed
was soll das sein das kann doch nicht sein
wieder delayed
das kann doch nicht sein
kaputtes
kaputtes zeug
die aktuelle katze lebt noch
man kann den wie toll irgendwie
steuern
ich hab den noch nie ausgerüstet bisher
109er ping
5er ping
kann ich das mal entscheiden
ganz kleine
aber trotzdem bemerkbar
ne ich glaube
was ist mit meinem ping los
das war ein anderer
jetzt fliegt er wie toll zu mir
den kann man nämlich irgendwie rumkommandieren
8700k
habe ich pc pc
wat
wie ist der da vorbeigekommen
ich muss noch ein paar videos machen
dass ich envidia nerven kann
dann sag ich envidia
ich brauch so fast 80 ep
was
wie viel stehen denn da rum
also die ping anzeige stimmt
ich guck mal oben links die ping anzeige an
die oben links ist deutlich realistischer
von hinten
der wird sich freuen
der dude
die sitzen bestimmt
noch da oben
in den zauen kannst du nicht ballern
ich check die spawn
ich check die spawns
in hauptquartier nicht ehrlich gesagt
wo sind die spawns in hauptquartier
jetzt wissen wir wo die spawns sind
da hinten
auf dem pc geht das so viel besser
was
wir zimmern da mal unser
ding rein
die ist übrigens viel zu langsam
viel zu langsam die predator
wat
wie du auch von der seite gestellt wirst
mehr negativ delay
wirklich
brauchen wir negativ delay
so haben wir noch mehr negativ delay
check hier nicht wo was ist
wo ist was
auch gegner
weil ich kapier die hauptquartier spawns nicht
kann mir jemand die hauptquartier spawns erklären kurz
komm mal nebenbei
was
ich check die hauptquartier spawns nicht
wo ist da was
zu viel negativ jetzt ist es positiv
was eigentlich
so so
jetzt spawnen wir auf der anderen seite
nein machen sie nicht
ich check hier die hauptquartier spawns
ist jetzt der delay wenigstens gut
kannst du ein custom motel rtx 2070 empfehlen
nein aber ich hatte das angebotene 7000 2000
2070 zu verlosen in meinem kotz stream
habe ich gesagt nee
ich will nicht
ich will mich in ruhe auf stream konzentrieren
also ihr seid verschont geblieben vor sellout
der sound kommt viel zu spät
ja was denn jetzt
alter das ist ja der wahnsinn wie kann das sein
jetzt gebatet mich jetzt gebatet mich
der sound ist lost wie geht das denn
ja was ist denn jetzt der sound zu spät oder zu früh
wie kann das denn sein dass sich das permanent ändert
wie kann sich das permanent ändert
ok wir testen das jetzt nochmal
guck mir das jetzt selbst an
tatsächlich der sound ist zu spät
wie geht das
wir haben überhaupt nichts gemacht
ich glaube ja das liegt an kotz
ich kann es mir zwar nicht erklären woran das liegt aber komisch
guck mal was die cpu auslastung sagt
wie gesagt
langweil mich
ich mein wir hatten ja noch nie irgendwelche sync probleme noch nie
war das denn vor
war das vor meinem umstellen von der auflösung war das war das da auch
oder ist es erst seitdem ich die auflösung umgestellt habe so
seitdem
ok
ich ziele das jetzt nochmal kurz ein bisschen
was passiert eigentlich wenn man das hier raus macht
ich mach das jetzt hier mal raus mal gucken was passiert
das will ich gar nicht
war das jetzt besser
die ersten zwei shots
das ist jetzt viel zu früh oder
meine güte was ist das für ein kratzer
jetzt ok oder
jetzt ist gut jetzt ist gut
was auch immer leute ich habe keinen schimmer was da abgeht
kein schimmer
jetzt haben wir natürlich den anfang der runde wieder
wieder komplett verschissen
ist jetzt
ich bin hier noch nie durch leute noch nie
eben noch hier gesessen
und stellt
mehr dreck habe sie sogar gesehen aus dem augenwinkel
das ist echt krass schnell
was
der vom runterfall
ich höre was rennen aber ich check null wo
was hat er denn fuck ich habe ich habe dings cam übersprungen ich wollte gucken was der hatte
performance ist ok ich müsste mal den aktuellen grafik treiber installieren
echt
da machen wir jetzt
die minimap ist immer aber die minimap zeigt nur was an sobald wir am start
wir machen jetzt brunnen stells
jetzt
Wir müssen nach oben an Alpha.
Wir haben Alpha verloren.
Du brauchst dich an Charlie.
Wir nehmen Bravo.
Nimm diese Positionen.
Hier geht übrigens was ab.
Ich höre übrigens um mich drum herum 30 Milliarden Gegner.
Das Haus hier ist übrigens richtig nice zum Hocken.
Zum Hocken.
Fuck.
Ich habe das falsche gezündet.
Ich wollte den VTOL zünden.
Fuck.
Ich will nicht diese verkackte Predator zünden.
Das war übelst Glück, dass ich das überlebt habe.
Ok.
Vielleicht macht man VTOL jetzt was.
Ach haben wir schön aufgeholt für den Anfang so verkackt.
What?
Ach in der Ecke wo sonst.
VTOL Harrier.
Es ist ein Harrier, den man steuern kann.
Ein 10er Killstreak.
Aber ich finde es eigentlich ganz nice, weil man weiter was machen kann, anstatt rumzusitzen
im Vergleich zum Chopper.
Äh.
Komm her.
Guck jetzt kann ich mit F kann ich jetzt hersteuern.
Ich habe keine Ahnung wo der Typ ist.
Wow.
Hör zu.
Oh nee.
Von der anderen Seite.
Es geht.
Für das, dass wir den Anfang so verkackt haben gleich mal ein 10er Killstreak.
Es spielt sich halt auf dem PC auch viel angenehmer als hier dieses umgegräbte auf der PS4.
Wobei ich diese Map immer noch irgendwie total räudig finde.
Ja ich dachte ich kriege es beide.
Sind das nicht die Frames?
Doch doch sind Frames.
Ich mache nach der Runde oder soll ich mal ein Grafikan Update machen?
Weil mein Grafiktreiber ist schon ein bisschen älter.
Einfach nur mal gucken wie gut das wirklich läuft.
Aber es kann danach sehr streng abkackt damit.
Der Dude ist auf der anderen Seite.
Was?
Wie hat der denn den Fight gewonnen bitteschön jetzt?
Wirklich das waren?
Ah Headshot Multiplier.
Shoot first die first.
Welche Grafik hat 1080 Ti?
Das haben sie immer noch nicht gefixt, dass man nicht aus dem Game raus kann.
Also mir macht das Game echt Spaß.
Vor allem jetzt auf dem PC aber das gekämpft wurde mir geradezu viel.
Ja das Gekämpfe ist es ist bei weitem nicht wie auf der Playstation 4.
Bei weitem nicht.
Und Stylers hat Stylers wahrscheinlich Stylers Stylers wahrscheinlich.
Das Gekämpfe ist ok aktuell aber ich glaube das liegt hauptsächlich daran.
Weil die Leute noch neu sind.
Die die von der PS4 hier am Start sind.
Die sind wahrscheinlich schon mehr Tryhard mäßig unterwegs.
Ja das ist auch immer geil.
Searching for a match unter.
Wir wollten noch mal schnell gucken hier.
Killstreaks haben sie noch mehr freigeschaltet.
Call in Heavy Assault, Helo Twin Charger, Control.
Ey komm wir nehmen das jetzt mal anstatt dem VTOL.
Nein der VTOL ok der VTOL ist.
Nee wir behalten mal den VTOL.
Und das Ding sackt wir nehmen Personal.
Wir nehmen Personal anstelle von der Missle.
Und nach der Runde erinnert mich mal dran Leute.
Nach der Runde müssen wir die Waffe modifizieren.
Ich hab die Waffe nämlich schon angefangen.
Guck mal wir haben jetzt Level 30.
Ich hab die auf der Playstation schon.
Was ist denn das jetzt?
Ich hab die nämlich auf der Playstation schon angefangen zu Leveln.
Damit ich mal die ganzen Attachments ausprobieren kann.
Weil die ist ziemlich ziemlich roh noch die M4.
Da ist kaum was dran hier.
Da ist glaube ich nur, die sind dran.
Ich glaube ein Stock ist dran.
Übrigens Leute bester Nadespot.
Ich hoffe ihr habt es euch gemerkt.
Der Nadespot ist ja wirklich gut wenn man sich gegen die Wand pfeffert.
Ja ich kann die Waffe ingame bearbeiten.
Aber das ist mir zu nervig das in der Runde rumzuklicken.
Kann man hier hin?
Geht das?
Wartet mal Leute.
Oh nice.
Also ich muss sagen mit den Maps wie sie das teilweise aufgebaut haben.
Da haben die sich schon ein bisschen was bei gedacht.
Suche Gegner please.
Gegner.
Keine G-Staff.
Oh das wäre fast triple.
Fast triple gewesen.
Triple.
Kommt man da von hier auch hoch?
Oh.
What?
Wie hat der das wieder gewonnen?
Das sind so komische Fights die check ich nicht.
Schieß zuerst Bamboo.
Da hat er in den Kopf geschossen.
Der Headshot Multiply ist halt echt übelst.
Ach hier ist gar kein Fenster.
Ich weiß nicht.
Alter fuck.
Ich wusste nicht dass sie die einmal aus dem Winkel sehen können.
Sonst wäre das jetzt Huge Play geworden.
Headshot ist leicht.
Naja wenn du mit dem Kopf den Gegner legst, dann muss er halt drauf ziehen und gibt dir
halt wieder.
Oh macht das Bock im Vergleich zur PS4 Leute ihr könnt euch das gar nicht vorstellen.
Ich bin ausgerastet auf der PS4.
Ok wenn ich die Gegner sehe.
Ok ich muss mal gucken dass ich in die andere Richtung gucke.
Ich gucke immer in die Richtung.
TDMS sack ich immer so richtig.
Ich gucke immer in die falsche Richtung.
Ok wo können die jetzt herkommen?
Du hast doch einen schon von der Seite kommen.
The fuck ich gucke ich sehe immer keine Gegner.
Ok das müssen wir anders machen.
TDM ist wirklich der Modus mit dem ich Abstand am meisten abkacke immer, weil ich null den
Fluss irgendwie drin habe wo was kommt.
Ich denke nicht.
Zu viel rumgehippe.
Erst echt mal ordentlich überlegen.
Oh nee ich muss rein, ich muss rein, ich muss rein.
Ist ausgeglichen oder?
Wir gewinnen, gewinnen wir?
Ja wir gewinnen.
Auch wenn wir nicht dazu beitragen.
Ok ich sollte nicht immer die gleichen Scheißwege laufen.
Fuck nicht gesprintet.
Jetzt gehen wir mal obelang.
Scheiße alter gut gedacht aber wieder zwei.
Ich weiß nicht wie ich, ich habe echt in dem Spiel keinen Schmerz wie man sich im TDM
richtig bewegen soll.
Immer ein easy win zwar mit übelst gesagt aber immerhin.
Die E-10 oder sowas was haben wir denn?
Ok man.
Wo ist denn die Anzeige was man hat?
Ah ja zu 70.
TDM weiß ich nicht.
TDM gucke ich irgendwie immer in die falsche Richtung.
Am meisten Bock macht mir eigentlich mittlerweile Domination oder tatsächlich dieser, also
was auch übelst nice ist dieser search and destroy Modus aber das ist halt nicht schön
zuzugucken.
So Waffe bearbeiten.
Also hier haben wir nichts was haben wir denn da zu bieten?
Nahkampf brauchen wir nicht.
Recoil control negativ dann aim down side speed.
Ne dann der Recoil von dem Ding ist jetzt nicht so dass das irgendwie sich kontroliert.
Damage range sagt auch.
Barrel, light white, bullet velocity, damage range, aim down side speed.
Hm.
Ich mein aim down side speed ist für ein Assault Reifel schon ziemlich wichtig ne.
Leider, leider ist mal wieder dieses dead page da unten vollkommen unbrauchbar.
Auf movement speed?
Movement speed, aim down side speed.
Na lassen wir erstmal.
Laser.
Laser kann man eigentlich immer dran machen.
Optics.
Aim down side speed.
Geht aber auch kein Optics dran.
Ich find das iron side von dem Ding echt gut.
Chat, chat ist heute nicht Q chat.
Chat macht nichts.
Idle sway control, aiming gun steadiness, walking speed, movement.
Ja das ist jetzt nicht so wild.
Allerdings ist das was es Vorteile bringt auch nicht so geil.
Aim walking movement speed.
Mein Idle sway juckt mich net.
Aiming gun steadiness ist jetzt auch net so, so das Problem.
Aber aim walking movement speed braucht halt auch kein Mensch.
Underbarrel.
Horizontal recoil, movement speed, nee movement speed will ich.
Movement speed will ich nicht einbüßen.
Magazine, extended max, movement speed.
Wir probieren mal aus was extended max.
Nee kommt mal aim down side speed und movement speed.
Das ist doof, nicht dumm.
Slide off hand ist schon mal gut.
Bringt auch nichts negatives.
Aim down side speed.
Sprint to fire speed, das ist cool, das wollen wir.
Idle sway control juckt mich null.
Das ist gut.
Ok.
Ah das ist doch schon mal net verkehrt.
So Perks, scavenger, scavenger, denn stirbt zu oft, das brauchen wir net.
Was haben wir ansonsten noch?
Take reduced damage from non killsie.
Ok das ist gut.
Das ist gut, die sterb laufen an irgendeinem kack.
Ghost.
Hardline.
Killchain.
Ah da kommen wir ja nicht hin.
Für wie sinnvoll haltet ihr Ghosts?
Ich meine es sind schon laufend UAVs am Start.
Spawn with ACP.
Das ist nicht schlecht.
Enemy flash stun an EMP effect, das ist auch net verkehrt.
Schauen wir mal so was hier.
Das neue.
Oh das gibt es doch nicht.
Ich bin mir noch unschlüssig irgendwie eben.
Generell finde ich die Waffen Upgrades so, da bin ich ziemlich gespannt.
Ich finde es cool, dass es anscheinend, anscheinend mal gucken wie sie fertig im Spiel ist.
Dass es anscheinend nicht so ultra viele Waffen gibt.
Also dass es jetzt nicht irgendwie 20 SMGs, 20 Assault Rifles oder sowas gibt.
Sondern dass es ein paar gibt, die sich unterscheiden.
Die man halt aufmotzen kann mit diesem Zeug.
Aber manche Sachen sind halt irgendwie doof.
Weil ich will doch nicht weniger Movement Speed.
Movement Speed und ADS Speed ist eigentlich so das blödeste was man einbüßen will.
Oh nee, wieder meine Lieblingsmap am Start.
Wir machen, ich renn jetzt durch den Tunnel.
Ah nee, da ist noch keiner.
Jetzt schreckt, Alter.
Mir kann keiner erzählen, dass das Game nicht irgendeine Form von Skill bzw.
Matchmaking Angleich hat.
Die ersten paar Runden waren die Gegner so extrem und bobs irgendwie.
Ich hab dich gehört, Kollege.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, ob hier was abgeht.
Wir machen den richtigen UAV an.
Oh fuck, Muni all.
Oh no.
Der Dude hat doch was dabei.
Ja.
Da kann ich jetzt nicht kontestlich meine Kackwaffe noch irgendwo hier rum.
Ich wollte die eigentlich aufheben und an die Amokiste gehen mit meiner Kackwaffe.
Nee, ich kann keine Munikiste werfen.
Ach doch, ich dachte, ich dachte, ich hab Dings dabei, das ist komische Barriere.
Dabei habe ich selbst eine Munikiste dabei.
Ich dachte, ich habe die Munikiste nicht dabei.
Ich dachte, ich habe die Munikiste, was haben wir eigentlich schon?
Pink 13.
Ah, damit kann man den.
Fuck.
Checks, hier null Wurdel an Gegner.
Pst.
Wohaha, null.
Woher wusste der, dass ich da liegt?
Hatten die UAV am Start oder was?
Ich lieg da voll im Busch.
Alter, ich lieg voll im Busch.
Wie?
Das war pre-fired auf die Ecke, volle Pulle.
Aber nein, ich lauf da einfach durch, ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Ist euer Ernst?
Rackspiel aus VDS raus.
Danke schön für den Start.
Was ist hier eigentlich schon wieder für Tri-Hard Action angesagt?
Das ist doch nicht normal.
Okay.
Ja.
Klar.
What the fuck, ey.
Was ist das in der, in der ADS?
Was ist das auf 60 Herzen?
Nö.
Abischnett.
So, wie sieht denn das jetzt mit Classic Card Update aus?
Was für ein GeForce Experience auch?
Ah, nervlich rum.
Oh nee.
Sag mal, welcher Voll-Dap, jetzt mal ganz ehrlich, welcher Voll-Dap bei Nvidia hat sich eigentlich ausgedacht,
dass man sich einloggen muss, um seinen Grafikkartentreiber updaten zu können.
Erst mal ohne Spaß, Leute.
Erst mal ohne Spaß, ne.
Wer hat sich das ausgedacht?
Das ist doch mal richtig hängen geblieben.
Warum soll ich mich einloggen für ein Grafikkartentreiber-Update?
Richtig dämlich, ja.
Oh, Mega-Lol, ja.
Nicht easy.
Oh, die Lol-3D ist ein bisschen, ein bisschen lag, ein bisschen.
Läuft mich nichts rund ein, noch mal Grafikkarten-Update und gucken.
Mit dem Friseur, klar.
Jeden Tag, aber fast jeden Tag.
Ich geh jetzt auch mal ins ADS.
Ich merk da keinen Unterschied.
Okay.
Man zockt hier, wir haben letztens Gears gespielt, allerdings ist das aktuelle Gears mega-scheiße
und macht keinen Bock.
Dann sollen wir noch...
Ja, geht mir übrigens um X.
Das aktuelle Gears ist...
Okay.
Ist so dumm.
Moment.
Ping-Not-Away-Level, hab ich das gerade richtig gesehen?
Alter, was gibt's mit den Gegnern schon wieder los, ey?
Es kann mir keiner erzählen, dass das Game nicht in irgendeiner Art und Weise so ein
Matchmaking dafür hat.
Ich mein, das wär ja auch irgendwo verständlich.
Irgendwo verständlich.
Hast du keinen Bock haben auf den Bullshit, die übelstes Loop abgefahren war?
Nope.
So und ich, Kollege.
Psst.
Wat?
Frostplay sollte schon funktionieren, ja?
Alter, was ist das wieder?
Oh, der hat mich gediegel-headshotted.
Der hat mich gediegel-headshotted.
Aber ich sag euch doch, das wird die neue Shotgun, ey.
Diese Map, die macht... ich hasse dieses verwinkelte Zeugs da, ey.
Frostplay bei einem Shooter, warum nicht?
Du kannst auf der Playstation einfach mit Maus und Tastatur spielen und gut ist.
Übrigens, wir sind in so einer scheiß Pose hier.
Eigentlich wirst du in die Mitte.
Natürlich mich, was sonst?
Psst.
Naja, ich take a cover, ich sowas von take a cover.
Bester Haus.
Da wenigstens haben wir einen, der was killt.
Da stellst du dich rum.
Oh Gott, ey.
Immer von der Seite.
Ja, Frostplay musste, glaube ich, besonders gesondert aktivieren, irgendwie.
Erst mal in die Mitte ins Haus, Bester.
Okay, nichts gebrochen.
Ich weiß noch, wo wir hingehen, wir gehen jetzt hier oben aufs Haus.
Was ist denn da?
Wo ist der Typ ist?
Fuck, ich hab nichts mehr.
Wo ist die Waffe?
Alter, wo ist deine Waffe?
Ach, Moment, ich hab doch meine Muni-Kiste.
Vergess immer meine Muni-Kiste.
Muni-Kiste.
Ist der tot dahinter?
Der liegt da doch noch.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, wenn du Zugang hast.
Ach, stimmt, du hast ja eine Code, ne?
Ja, können wir machen.
Aber dann streame ich nicht.
Also, wenn wir zusammen spielen wollen, das wird zu anstrengend dann auch mit Labern und
Dingen und alles zusammen.
Aber ich hätte schon Bock.
Oder sag mal so, wir können auch theoretisch morgen spielen.
Ich meine, ich hab eh nur noch eine Stunde Zeit.
Ich nullchecke, wo hier was kommt, er.
Alter, kannst du mal rüberspringen bitte?
Da kann ich ja schon rausgehen.
Wenn ich da rausgehe, bin ich down.
Gibs nicht, ey.
Fuck.
Jetzt hätten wir vielleicht doch das Recon.
Alter.
Wie läuft man auf diesen Laps am besten?
Echt kein Plan.
Die Maps sind nicht, also HQ Spawns hab ich eh noch nicht gecheckt.
Weil jetzt ist hier irgendwie wieder vorbei.
Und dann peekst du um die Ecke mit Eindeutig Advantage und kriegst auf die Fresse.
Aber es spielt sich viel angenehmer als auf der Playstation.
Hier über uns.
Alles in der Welt kommt man da hoch.
What?
Oder wo war der Kerl?
Was geht eigentlich mit dem Ping?
Moment, ich glaube, ich hab da einen.
Ein nuller Ping hat da einen, okay.
Ich glaube, ich erkenne da einen Zusammenhang.
Sobald man das aufmacht, spackt der Ping.
Oh.
Komisch, guck mal.
Wenn man das Fenster tappt.
Ja, guck mal, wenn man das Fenster tappt, geht der Ping hoch.
Hä, was das?
Okay, was auch immer.
Jetzt hab ich schon nie gesehen, dass der Ping hochgeht, wenn man das Death Fenster tappt.
What?
Die Gegner sind mega krass in den Ecken.
Gehen wir mal gleich.
Alter, was ist denn das hier?
Der Typ hat sich auch gehalten.
Okay.
Haben wir sogar eine Kill-Can?
Steht aus, die Server, genau.
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Ja.
So, ich lock mich mal in den Grafikkartentreiber ein.
Weil man ja, wenn man sich ja einloggen muss, dass man seine.
NVIDIA.
NVIDIA, NVIDIA.
Oh nee, das ist ein.
Fuck, ein NVIDIA-Account ist was, das kann ich nicht zeigen.
Was muss ich, Captures lösen mit Autos?
Big Brain.
Login.
I'm not a robot, ich weiß, dass ich kein Robot bin.
Okay, nice, da sind wir wieder.
Drei was.
Was?
Moment.
Ich dachte Dedicated Servers on all platforms, Leute.
Na ja, dann gucken wir mal.
Dann gucken wir mal.
You have the latest.
Hat mir das Game nicht eben noch erzählt, ich soll updaten.
Debated würde ich sagen.
Always lagged, seht ihr das?
Aber ich will ein bisschen mehr FPS, wäre noch schon cool.
Aber an Anti-Alasen kann es eigentlich nicht.
Ah, wir sind in den Chopper-Gunner-Game reingejoint.
Das ist komisches Anti-Alasen bei denen.
Das sieht jetzt vielleicht instant übelst verdreffend aus, aber dafür sieht es auf der anderen Seite schärfer aus.
Das sollte mit echte Multi-Sampling eigentlich nicht passieren, weil es da einfach in der höheren Auflösung geändert wird.
Okay.
Sag mal, kann das sein, dass die Gegner gerade voll gebashed werden hier?
Huge bash.
Also ich bin mir nicht, ich bin mir unschlüssig.
Ich bin mir unschlüssig, welche Map ich weniger mag.
Die?
Oder die Wüsten-Map. Also Gunrunner ist auf jeden Fall bis jetzt mit Abstand meine Lieblings-Map.
Die ist so normal.
Kann man da rüber? Oh, nice.
Ist aber nix mal da.
Camp-Action.
Da oben sitzt auch immer gerne einer drin.
Da kann man eigentlich nicht lang.
Ja, bitte.
Was willst du denn?
Keiner da?
Witzten sie im Häuschen hier drin?
Easy Win. So geil. Reingekommen. Reingekommen in das Game.
Zwei Chopper-Gunner am Start gewesen. Instant Win. Perfekt.
Ja, Grafikkarte.
Ah ne, wir hatten geguckt, Grafikkarte war schon auf aktuellsten Stand.
Okay.
Ja, warum meckert das Game denn dann?
Vielleicht die den Beta-Treiber machen oder so?
Nächste Runde.
Ja, aber eher glatt mal runter.
Ich glaube, das ist zu zweit ganz nice. Wir könnten auch mal eine Runde dieses Zwei Spiel, wobei das halt auch extrem anstrengend ist.
Ja, ich weiß, 40 Gigabyte.
Sehr schön, was du sagst. Nice.
Ich mache ja auch aktuell wieder viele Videos.
Also Gunrunner ist mit Abstand meine Lieblings-Map bisher in der Beta. Die ist einfach normal.
Die Maps sehen zwar alle langweilig aus, aber die hat wenigstens nicht so 30 Milliarden Ecken.
Und geht irgendwie noch. Gunrunner ist cool.
Ihr Krasna-Raid zackt. Die ist saumäßig groß, hat 50 Milliarden Fenster und du bist eigentlich nur die permanent am rumrennen und rennst den Gegner, die irgendwo herglitschen.
Die Wüsten-Map mit dem Tunnel, die geht so. Was ist noch eine Map? Was gab es noch? War es das?
Oder gab es noch eine?
Habe ich eine Map vergessen?
Oder gab es nur die, der Ping?
Cool. Übrigens, dass es kein Server-Browser gibt, ist auch ein bisschen lächerlich, oder?
Jetzt ist er unten.
Ob das war es? Ja ich glaube auch, dass es das war.
Ich glaube auch, dass es das war.
What?
Ich meine, das war es so. Was soll der Typ dagegen machen jetzt?
Was?
Voll um die Ecke er.
Bringst dieses... Ich habe ja Slide of Hand ausgerüstet, das merkt man irgendwie überhaupt nicht hier.
Kein Unterschied.
Habe ich jetzt vorbei.
Die Entscheidung mit K.D. oder nicht K.D. ist ja auch nicht so richtig konsequent.
Manchmal ist es drinne, manchmal ist es in-game drinne, manchmal ist es nicht drinne.
Ich stehe nicht.
Ich habe was gehört. Auch nicht.
Hat sich was geändert? Nö, es ist im Prinzip nur noch das Gleiche.
Ich habe immer noch keine Ahnung, wo was herkommt.
Ich habe nur noch keine Ahnung, wo das Gegner herkommt, das ist ganz schlimm.
Und immer da, wo man nicht checkt, ist einer. Das spielt man ja auch so blurry.
Das liegt tatsächlich am Anti-Alasing.
Es sieht zwar kacke aus ohne Anti-Alasing, aber es ist deutlich schärfer auf Range ohne Anti-Alasing.
Komisch, ne?
Normalerweise sollte ordentliches Multi-Sampling da überhaupt, sollte das eigentlich eher besser machen als schlechter.
Alter, an jeder Ecke auf dieser verfickten Map kann irgendwo einer rausgucken.
Autsch. Ey, lass mich raus hier.
Ich gehe da nicht rein, Leute, ich gehe da nicht rein.
Ich meine, das ist so ein, du springst, ich bin auf einmal nur Granate da.
Da haben wir doch vorbeigezielt. Aber es ist so krass, dass...
Also richtiges Multi-Sampling, also MSAA, darf auf jeden Fall nicht dazu beitragen, dass es blurry wird.
Und zweifaches Anti-Alasing mit einer ordentlichen Grafikkarte frisst eigentlich nicht wirklich was Großartiges.
Ja, Multi-Sampling ist im Prinzip klar, ist doppelte Auflösung.
Was ist denn das da über mir für ein Stells-Ding?
Ist das ein Chopper-Gunner? Was ist das Chopper-Gunner?
Ach, geil. Okay, bleib mal hier stehen.
Die Map ist jetzt dauer-sichtbar, ja.
Es ist so eklig zu spielen teilweise.
Die Map ist dauer-sichtbar, aber es wird nichts angezeigt.
Ich weiß in dem Spiel nicht, wo ich hinlaufen soll, das ist mein Problem.
Warum sieht denn das so hässlich aus?
Schaut euch mal mein Ironsight an, was ist denn damit los?
Ich hab echt keine Ahnung, wo ich immer hinlaufen soll, das ist so...
Verwinkelt alles irgendwie.
Das Ding ist Gun-Runner gut. Die ist schön klein.
Kannst ein paar Tricks machen, aber nicht so viele.
Boah, ich bin gerade durch eine geschlossene Tür gerannt.
Wo stellt es dir irgendwo was?
Der Schatten, ja, das ist komisch.
Aber wenn ich Dings hier anmache...
Jetzt ist es okay.
Guck mal, jetzt ist es auch viel schärfer.
Aber es ist Post-Processing und ich hab das Gefühl, es ist jetzt Input-Lagi-mäßig mehr.
Als vorher.
Ich hoffe, ich werde irgendwann mal checken, wie man die Maps spielen muss.
Weil entweder, wenn ich über die Map komme, ohne zu sterben, dass ich irgendwo weggehit-klitscht werde...
Dann renne ich in eine Region, wo nichts ist...
Oder ich renn' voll in den Head-Clitch rein.
Da ist ein Schimmer raus.
Ich hab echt keinen Plan, wo was ist.
Habt ihr den Headshot-Multiplier gesehen?
Übels krass.
Habt ihr den Headshot-Multiplier gerade gesehen?
Ich hab einfach random auf den Typ gezielt.
Ich hab richtig einen weißen Headshot getroffen, aber instantan.
Auf was hast du das jetzt gestellt?
Auf Film...
Filmig-SMA...
Aber so Post-Processing-Zeug sagt...
Post-Processing ist Müll.
Ich schalte normalerweise jegliche Post-Processing-Sachen immer ab.
Alles weg.
Wenn du das weg machst...
Machen wir das mal aus. Machen wir das mal an. Mal gucken, was passiert.
Genau, deswegen kein Post-Processing.
Sackt.
Ich weiß jetzt auch, warum sich's viel angenehmer spielt als auf der PS4.
Ist mir gerade aufgefallen, weil ich noch vor dem ersten Match das Foff hochgestellt hab.
Das wird's sein, ne? Der Ping.
Wie kommt man da oben drauf?
Pass auf, Kill.
Da kann ich jetzt nicht peeken, da sind zwei.
Da kann er ins Fenster kommen.
What? Alter, wie soll das denn funktionieren?
Mehr als draufschießen kann ich noch nicht.
Na gut, das trifft nicht richtig. Wenn ich da einfach geradeaus...
Zitschek Max.
Alter, was haben die denn für geile Stimmen, Alter?
Reload.
Kann man hier einfach aus dem Fenster was rausklitschen?
Wie?
Ich war doch drauf. Hat sogar Hintmarker gegeben.
Okay, das war jetzt verkackt, aber gut.
Nee, nee, Kollege, ich laufe dir das nicht nach, das glaubst du doch selbst nicht.
Netcode? Na, ich weiß nicht. Also, das fühlt sich bis jetzt gut an.
Man stirbt immer noch extrem schnell. Und ich hab immer noch keine Ahnung, wie ich das gescheit spielen soll.
Ich mein, du wirst auf jede Ecke gepiekt. Aus jeder Ecke.
Wie zum Teufel hat der Typ 13? Null, Alter.
Wie spielt man das richtig? Die Time to Kill finde ich auch gut.
Ich muss mir erst mal in Ruhe hinsetzen.
Wie man hier läuft drauf. Weil in der Regel läuft man rein oder es ist nichts.
Okay, ich hab echt keine Ahnung.
Ich muss mal kurz ein neues Game suchen, das ist mir gerade zu ätzend.
Reload? Klingt fast so. Was sagt der denn? Ich hör da gar nicht richtig drauf.
Ach, hast du den Key gekriegt? Ja, nice. Nice. Nice.
Haha, guck mal hier unten. Wird schon wieder rumgeflamt.
Ach ja, ähm, warte mal. Wir machen was anderes. Ich wollte ja mal eine MP5 Klasse machen.
Da kommt schon ein Shotgunner drin. Auk? Oder mit Auk?
Oh, was kommt man da? Attachn.
Nichts gescheites. An der Barrel fix. Na gut. Und ganz das Ding.
Das auf jeden Fall, wenn wir was machen können. Ja, wir lassen mal Heartline drin.
Flash, Stim. Ach, man hat jetzt einen Stim. Oh, nice. Das brauchen wir. Stim.
Das brauch ich. Beste. 1000 als TI hab ich drin. Ja, Stim.
Beste. Jetzt kann's weitergehen. Edge Summary. Gibt's nicht.
Ja, Next Unlock debated uns ruhig. Wisst ihr was ich cool fände?
Wenn die zum offenen Beta das Level erhöhen würden noch ein bisschen.
Ich würde ja echt gerne mal diese Perk hier ausprobieren. Das da.
20 ist Max Level, ja.
Das hat das Level von der PS4 übernommen. Das heißt, ich war schon fast Max Level.
Oh, nicht wieder diese komische Map.
Kack map. Kack map. Oh, Alter.
Wo kommt der langgestellte Typ jetzt?
Das hat gereicht. Auch gut.
Was ist Stim? G? F hab ich doch richtig getroffen.
Was ist das? Best amount spot ever.
Hallo?
Da kannst du nicht durch. Also die Mitte kannst du echt nicht gehen.
Was zum Teufel ist Stim?
Was für ein Knopf ist Stim? F? Q? Ah, das gleiche. Ach, nicht F.
Oh, wir haben Vitorl am Start. Nice.
Es ist, es ist Q. Genauso wie Flash. Hätte ich halt lecken können.
Ist ja auch Ersatz für ne Flash. Lulve.
Haben wir noch ganz gut gebashed, jetzt wo wir reingekommen sind.
Schön um die Ecke. Ich hoffe mal, Vitorl bash den Typ jetzt. Ich mein, dafür ist er da.
Du stellst über dem rum und machst aber nichts. Jetzt hat er ihn. Vitorl hat ihn geschreckt.
Äh, okay. Da kann man auch nicht. Also rechtsrum finde ich es auf der Map besser.
Ich meine, Vitorl ist weg. Guckt euch, wenn ihr Noob-Gameplays sehen wollt.
Also richtig krasse Noob-Bash-Gameplays. Guckt mal teilweise auf YouTube, ey.
Da hast du Leute, die... Och Gott, war das schlecht, ey.
Darf ich so viel labern? Da hast du teilweise Gegner, die drehen sich nicht mal um, wenn sie beschossen werden.
Huge NA war das.
Ich bin den Kot immer hin und her gerissen, ob ich die Maus jetzt, wie ich es jetzt hab,
ein bisschen schneller lasse, dass du dich halt auch ordentlich drehen kannst, ohne dass du hier den krassen CSGO-Kurbler machen musst.
Und dann hab ich halt manchmal das Problem, wenn da irgendwie sowas langsam sich close bewegt, den ordentlich zu treffen.
Oder aber, ob ich es langsamer mache und dann halt nicht gescheit drehen kann.
In Battlefield ist es kein Ding. Da ist es easy. Dann nimmst du auf jeden Fall die schnellere.
Bisschen schneller. Wie groß ist dein Mauspedding? Keine Ahnung. 40 Zentimeter oder so?
Nee, nicht 40 Zentimeter. 30? 30? Ja, so 30 Zentimeter würd ich sagen.
Ja, gut. In CS ist es ganz klar. Das stimmt schon eher. Das kannst du nicht vergleichen.
Wenn du in CS ein bisschen Brain hast, wie du spielst, weißt du eigentlich, in welche Richtung du gucken musst.
Zumindest so grob, ja. Natürlich können die Gegner wirklich so rumfaken und alles andere.
In der Regel hast du so ungefähr eine Ahnung, wo du hinzucken musst.
Ich mein, es kommt da zwar ab und zu. Wie zum Teufel spielt man da jetzt 36-9?
Ich hab überhaupt keine Gegner gefunden die ganze Runde.
Ach nee, wir waren ja auch erst... Waren wir von Anfang an in der Runde überhaupt drinne?
Nee, wir sind reingechollen, ne?
Download-Server, ja die sind übelst am kaputtgehen, wenn man das so hört.
Wahrscheinlich weil der Typ die gekillt hat, ja. Wahrscheinlich, ich hab nix gefunden.
Und wenn wurde irgendwo geil geheadclitched?
Hast du Bildrauschen? Nee, das hab ich ausgestellt. Sofort ausgestellt.
Bildrauschen, zack.
Aber ich hab's jetzt schon von vielen Leuten gehört, dass die Download-Server ziemlich im Arsch sind.
So, also hier ist linksrum am Anfang auf jeden Fall am besten.
Linksrum und dann aufs Dach.
Und dann verrecken. Aber ich find das ist der beste Weg.
Ich hör übrigens 30 Gegner, die bei mir rumrennen.
Alter, die sind schon wieder übel.
Die sterben auch gut.
Guck mal, der erst hat schon 5. Ich hab gerade erst einen Gegner gefunden.
Was soll ich da jetzt mit der Shotgun über die Range machen?
Also ich weiß immer noch nicht wie ich das Spiel gescheit...
Ich hör was hinter mir.
Wie ich das Spiel gescheit spielen soll.
Oh fuck, ich hab ne Stim.
Ah, das gibt's doch nicht.
Warum ist der Kack jetzt immer leer, wenn man's braucht?
Aber ohne Scheiß, das kann mir keiner erzählen, dass diese Gegner nicht irgendwie gematcht werden.
Ich mein, das ist doch nicht normal.
Die gehen alle so ab. Die jumpen sich einen ab und machen und tun, aber das spielt keiner.
Fuck, das spielt keiner irgendwie halbwegs normal.
Wo ist was?
Oh fuck, warum mach ich jetzt mein UAV an?
Jetzt will ich's einmal umlauf, weil ich mir denke, kommt keiner in your face direkt.
Die Casuals spielen keine Bit. Das stimmt.
Aber es ist teilweise echt krass die Leute.
Du musst die ganze Zeit dich übelst anstrengen.
Du läufst geradeaus und hast irgendwas in der Fresse.
Ich weiß echt nicht, was ich da machen soll.
Wenn wir alles draufballern, kann ich noch nicht.
Das Stealth-Clown, den bräuchten wir jetzt.
Ich sehe nichts da. Ich finde keine Gegner.
Wenn ich einen finde, ist er gerade tot.
Geile Range für das Ding.
Das wäre zu dumm.
Das wäre echt zu dumm.
Er sitzt da drin und guckt die ganze Zeit in eine Richtung.
Ich finde die Waffen manchmal viel zu wild.
Eigentlich finde ich das ganz gut, wie sie das gemacht haben.
Wie sich die Waffen anfühlen, finde ich das Game nicht schlecht.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie ich spielen soll.
Die Gegner sind alles so krass.
Du musst ja schon jede Ecke jumpen und permanent troppen.
Die schwitzen übertrieben.
Ich bin gematcht mit Controller-Spielern.
Die spielen bestimmt mit Sim.
Und Auto-Aim wird alles weg.
Die ersten Runden haben viel Spaß gemacht.
Jetzt ist wieder das typische Vorbestell.
Es wurde mir schon oft offeriert.
Mal gucken, ich warte erst mal ab.
Ich spiele die Beta eine ganze Weile.
Mal gucken, ob ich da reinkomme in das Game.
Ah, der hat einen MP7.
Keine Press-Copy, eine Influencer.
Ich möchte, dass ihr das Game geil findet.
Hat der gerade den VTOL gebashed mit der Missile?
Was soll ich denn machen?
Ich schieße drauf, bin tot.
Was geht mit den Gegnern ab?
Das ist doch nicht normal.
Das kann mir doch keiner erzählen, dass das normal ist.
Ich bin mit 35 nicht mit den ultra krassen Überreactions.
Das ist doch nicht normal.
Das war so wild da.
Hör zu.
Pfefferhens.
Das Geschenke geht mir auch auf den Sack.
Das ist mein Dude, den hab ich auch nicht auf der Map gesehen.
Oh Mann, ich wollt ne Flash werfen, ich hab ja ne Stimme dabei.
Nee, den Shake kann man nicht abschalten.
Bin es nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Okay, wir dürfen nicht immer die...
Oh, der wreckt die aber grad Hardcore.
Die guten Maps gibt's dann im DLC.
Gunrunner ist cool, Gunrunner macht Spaß. Die hier, die Map, die wir jetzt hier spielen, die ist cool. Die mag ich.
Der kommt da rein. Alter, was ist das? Da wird ja nur noch geschleidet.
Da wird ja nur noch der da gemacht.
Du musst jede Ecke jumpen, du musst jede Ecke prüfen.
Das ist voll anstrengend.
Gegner?
Fuck man, links der oder kommt rechts einer rum?
Alter, was zum Teufel geht mit den Dudes ab?
Ich bin permanent am rennen, finde nichts oder sterbe an irgendeinem Typ der da sitzt.
Ich hab echt keine Ahnung wie ich das Spiel spielen muss.
Da war übrigens einer.
Jetzt spawnen sie auf der anderen Seite, ne?
Und es pixeln übelst dahinten, da riechst du gar nichts.
Der detached nicht automatisch.
Nee, den Laser sieht man nicht.
Aber es nervt halt auch, was ist das?
Ach, der Typ, das war das mit dem Chopper-Gunner, der eben 50 Leute gekillt hat, ne?
Wenn man draufschießt und es passiert nichts, ist das auch nice.
Also ich guck mal, wie das morgen wird, aber es ist echt komisch, ey.
Man, die ersten Runden waren richtig nice, ja?
Das ist wirklich merkwürdig.
Aber es spielt sich schon mal um Welten besser als auf der PS4.
Wie läuft das? Ach, das Spiel läuft eigentlich ganz gut.
Letztendlich für das, wie es ausschaut und gewisse Dinge.
Also das könnte auch durchaus noch ein paar FPS mehr haben.
Nach den ersten Runden kickt das Matchmaking rein.
Na ja, eigentlich hätte ich schon gematcht.
Nicht auf dieser Plattform, auf dieser Plattform war ich nicht gematcht.
Aber es ist mega krass, ne?
Leute, der Unterschied, ohne Scheiß, ne?
Der Unterschied zwischen den ersten zwei, drei Runden und jetzt ist der Wahnsinn, ey.
Jetzt musst du jede Ecke Jumpshotten, jedes Ding Dropshotten, jeden Winkel Pre-Amen.
Und hast trotzdem den Typen, die um die Ecke fliegen und den Kopf schießen.
Das ist echt nicht normal.
Nicht gesehen.
Ja, aber wenn ich hier den absolut krassen Rusher-Typ mache,
dass ich auch ein paar Kills abkriege, dann endet das so.
Vielleicht soll ich es doch ein bisschen runterstellen.
Oh, Tür zu.
Okay, jetzt sind sie eben wieder da hinten am Start.
Wir kämpfen jetzt hier.
Da ist nichts.
Fuck man, ich bin zum falschen Zeitpunkt gesprungen dort.
Fazit bis jetzt, übertrieben anstrengend.
Übertrieben anstrengend, ich sage es euch ja.
Ich hab eigentlich gehofft, da hinten steht noch einer, macht aber nicht.
Fuck, irgendwie dachte ich, da ist was.
Was ich hättet.
Ich hab irgendwie hinter mir was gehört.
Ich muss übrigens mehr Head-Clitch und Head-Clitch zu wenig.
Head-Clitch zu wenig Leute.
Wo ist er?
Das siehst du da übrigens kaum in der Ecke.
Ich head-glitch jetzt auch.
Die Gegner sind zu clever.
Die Gegner sind zu clever, das kannst du nicht machen.
Aber du musst echt um jeden Kill so übertrieben fighten.
Und ich meine, ich war die Runde ganz okay.
Aber die anderen sind einfach krasser.
Die wirft mal zurück.
Ich dachte, man kann zurückwerfen.
Gott, stirbt nicht.
Aber es ist echt hart, es ist wirklich hardcore.
Es ist kein Spaß, das ist wirklich massiv.
Massive Arbeit, ich sag's euch.
Könnt ihr euch nicht vorstellen.
Das ist wirklich Arbeit.
Also Spaß ist was anderes.
Okay, das war Fail.
Ich war nicht auf dem Mousepad richtig drauf.
Aber es ist wirklich anstrengend.
Ja, ich bin aber gleich off.
Das ist mir zu anstrengend.
Das hat mit entspannt eine Runde spielen echt nichts zu tun.
Jede Ecke Jumpen, jede Ecke Pre-Aim, jede Ecke Pre-Fire.
Nicht normal.
Dann spiel ich lieber Black Ops 1 Free Fall für alle Zeit.
Es ist wirklich, Danny, genau das richtige Ebenbau.
Das ist wirklich krass.
Das ist echt krass.
Dass ich hier so gerade mal so ein bisschen positive Bilanz halte,
ist schon übelster Tryhard angesagt.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht genau wo, ehrlich gesagt.
Hier was, kommt hier was?
Fuck, Alter.
Woher kommt?
Habe ich noch Ghost by?
Ist das vielleicht der Grund, warum dann?
Moment, fuck.
What?
Ich habe das jetzt ja.
Ich habe kein Ghost mehr bei, oder?
Moin, Heide.
Global Elite.
Ich bräuchte jetzt mal ein Global Elite hier.
Warum?
Warum ist der hinter mir auf einmal?
What the fuck?
Es ist der Wahnsinn.
Das ist so anstrengend.
Es ist so anstrengend.
Es ist krass.
Windows 8.
Ach, das Game ist DirectX 12, vielleicht?
Na gut, es gibt wahrscheinlich keine Optionen darum zu stellen.
Es gibt eigentlich keinen Grund, dass das DirectX 12 ist,
so wie ich mir das angucke.
Okay, eine Runde machen wir noch.
Eine Runde machen wir noch.
Dann gehe ich pennen.
Windows 8.
Ja, Streamverbot.
Es gab ein Windows 8.
Das vergessen viele.
Das ist das Windows, was eigentlich kaum einer verwendet hat.
Was ist Max Level während der Beta?
20.
Ehex, wir spielen morgen.
Ich bin morgen um...
Wobei morgen ist...
Ja, doch, ich muss sogar morgen 13.30 abhauen,
weil ich habe gelesen, es ist wieder irgendeine
zweite Weltkriegsbombe-Dingsentschärfung oder so.
Wenn ich da zu lange in Frankfurt rumstelse,
dann komme ich nicht heim.
Also ich haue 13.30 ab.
Und dann können wir bashen.
Ach, die ist heute.
Hab ich mich verguckt?
Hä?
Das heißt, ich muss mir morgen gar keine Gedanken machen,
dass ich heimkomme, oder wie?
Egal, ich gehe trotzdem um 13.30.
Ich habe mich schon heute überlegt, ob ich nicht
Homeoffice machen soll.
Nein, nicht zum Kot spielen, sondern dass ich schneller
daheim bin.
Wie alt bist du?
Warte mal, anhand meiner krassen Reactions,
wie alt ich bin.
Warte mal.
Hier.
Huge Plays.
Was meinst du, wie alt ich bin?
Wir machen jetzt physisches Alter und Ingame-Alter.
Also ich meine, diese Huge Plays und Big Brain Kills hier,
dann würde ich mal sagen 13, oder?
Okay, wo sind die Gegner?
Wo ist Huge Kills machen?
Oh, fuck.
Sag mal, heißt der Gegner da wirklich?
Heißt der wirklich Piss Schlitz?
Sehe ich das richtig?
Heißt der Piss Schlitz?
Alter, wo sind die Gegner hier?
Okay, das war dumm.
Hätte ich ran, hätte ich ADSen sollen.
Anhand der Reactions 60 plus anhand der Stimme 19.
Da liegst du, wenn du das durchzweiteilst,
wenn du das zusammenrechnest und durchzweiteilst,
gar nicht so voll.
Das ist nicht so voll.
Gar nicht so falsch.
Wie hat Desert Eagle 9 Kills?
Ich verstehe das nicht.
Ich bin permanent am rumjumpen über die Map,
am rumrennen über die Map und dann am verraten,
was ich jetzt auch irgendwie nicht hätte anders machen können.
Also ich blick das nicht.
Das ist echt krass.
Also ich habe noch nie in keinem CoD
so krasse Competition gesehen,
wie in diesem...
Also im...
The fuck?
Nee, nee, ja, Knappe 40 ist übertrieben.
Also nicht ganz.
Ich meine, was soll ich denn machen hier?
Ich komme übertrieben hilflos in dem Spiel vor.
Du musst mega tryharden,
dass du überhaupt 1-1 bist.
Jetzt kriegt er aufs Maul.
What the fuck?
Ich bin pre-fired um die scheiß Ecke gelaufen.
Was ist das?
Alter, was ist das?
Ich bin zu outdated.
Ich bin offensichtlich zu outdated, wenn ich sowas sehe.
Ich bin wirklich zu outdated.
What the fuck?
Was ist das?
Was willst du da machen?
Das ist doch nicht normal.
Das ist doch echt nicht normal.
Hallo?
Ich meine,
ich stehe um die Ecke, pre-fire
und da kommen alle gechoppt.
Headshot, bin ich bedauert?
Nee, also...
Das ist so krass in dem Game.
Ich weiß nicht, was da...
Fuck, okay.
Ich kann mich da noch nicht mal irgendwie aufheben.
Das ist einfach unglaublich.
Ja.
Da kannst du echt deinstallieren.
Du kannst direkt...
Du kannst direkt uninstall machen.
Oh!
Ich hab 5-5!
Ja, E-AX.
Doch, E-AX, du bist besser.
Du bist der Pro.
Du musst besser sein.
Wo ist denn hier was?
Ich hab ja immer noch das Gefühl, Leute,
dass die...
Dass die Chopper-Gunner-Typen
jetzt nicht hier die run-and-gun-Dudes
über der Map sind.
Sondern dass der Typ da hinten zum Beispiel ist.
Der da, der schon das ganze Game
dahinten drin sitzt.
Ja, wieder schön von der Seite.
So.
Leute.
Let's vorbei.
Easy.
Bleib jetzt hier stehen.
Pre-Fired auf die Ecke!
Was zum Teufel soll ich denn da machen?
Ja.
Ich laufe jetzt einfach mal durch
und kill dich.
Easy.
Ey, es ist der Wahnsinn.
Also...
Ich hab das doch nie...
Also, ich hab das in keinem Game bisher gesehen,
dass das noch...
Dass das so krass ist, ey.
Ich weiß nicht, wie genau das funktioniert.
Das Gunplay wirkt nicht sehr Cod-artig,
auch noch.
Ich finde schon.
Komm du links um die Ecke gesprungen.
Die Taktik war wohl halb geier anscheinend.
Wobei ich immer noch nicht weiß,
wie man...
Wie das geht.
Also, wenn ich so jemand peek,
der in der Ecke steht,
bin ich gleich kaputt.
Sofort.
Übrigens, hier...
Ich mein, der...
Guck mal, ich muss mich übelst anstrengen
für ein 1-1-1-1.
Ich mein, ich mach jetzt auch nicht
die optimalsten Routen und sonst was.
Es kann doch nicht sein,
dass du so übertrieben dich anstrengen musst permanent.
Ich bin kurz drin,
als ob du das Glück hättest, mich zu bashen.
Und außerdem habe ich nicht gecheckt,
wo ich lang rennen muss.
Ich glaube, das Beste ist echt,
man setzt sich in die Mitte
ins Häuschen irgendwie
und macht sonst nix.
Ja, im Häuschen sitzen ist gut.
Ich dachte, der fliegt noch mal.
Okay, Häuschen sitzen ist das Beste.
Häuschen sitzen Beste.
Nein, Max, Häuschen sitzen.
Nicht rausgehen.
Häuschen sitzen.
Serious, Max, Dankeschön.
Du rushst jetzt nicht raus.
Du bleibst jetzt einfach in dem scheiß Haus sitzen.
Fuck, ich hab nix mehr.
Okay, ohne Scheiß, Leute.
Ich hab's kapiert.
Rushen ist einfach für'n Arsch.
Rushen ist einfach kacke.
Irgendwo in die Mitte ins Haus und abwarten.
Hat sich jetzt schon öfters bewährt.
Kein Rushen.
Ja, offensichtlich hast du grad gesehen.
Häuschen sitzen.
Das heißt, das Schwierige ist,
wer kommt zuerst ins Haus und setzt sich fest.
Wo war der denn?
Oh nee, oder?
Okay, Max, du bist wieder rausgelaufen.
Und bist deswegen zurecht gestorben.
Das geht in diesem Teil nicht.
Du kannst nicht rauslaufen.
Du musst im Haus bleiben.
Download is ready.
Ich muss jetzt ins Bett.
What?
What the fuck, ey?
Was geht mit den Gegnern ab?
Was sind das für Gegner, Alter?
Das ist doch nicht normal.
Das ist doch echt nicht normal.
Okay, ja, ich hab' vorbei.
Ich hab' einmal...
Ich hab' am Anfang...
Ich hab' so gemacht.
Guck, der Gegner war da.
Und ich hab' beim Laufen so gemacht.
Ich war ne Mikrosekunde nicht drauf oder so.
Ich war hinter dem.
Der gibt mir den krassesten 360-Turn-On-in-your-Face,
den ich lange gesehen hab'.
Alter, das ist doch Wahnsinn.
Ich kann das...
Das ist so anstrengend, dieses Spiel.
Das ist so unglaublich anstrengend.
Das kann ich ja lange spielen.
Das...
Da flippe ich aus bei.
Das hat noch nicht mal was mit Tryhard hoch.
Zählt so...
Die sind halt...
Die sind halt gut, die Leute, ja?
Aber es kann doch nicht sein, dass nur...
Die nur so Dudes in dem Team sind.
Bis die Glück gehört auch dabei, so was zu treffen, ja?
Wahnsinn.
Es ist echt Wahnsinn.
Und der Ping geht auf 120.
Wird besser, wenn alle spielen noch mal.
Vielleicht.
Aber wie die abgehen?
Ich weiß nicht, ist das alles irgendwelche...
X, CS, Rainbow Six, Bros?
Oder was ist das?
Äh, ja, du kannst einfach auf Nein drücken.
Du kannst einfach auf Nein drücken.
Das hat mir das...
Ich hab den neuesten Grafiktreiber und das Spiel hat mir auch erzählt, ich soll updaten.
Totaler Blödsinn.
Ja, Ping-Anzeige, ja.
Ich hab jetzt gar nicht geguckt.
Wisst ihr, was wir jetzt mal machen?
Wir machen jetzt mal eine Sache.
Machen wir jetzt mal...
Edit Loadout?
Haben wir da jetzt irgendwas für...
Oh fuck Leute, ich muss ins Bett.
Ich muss pennen.
Die deutschen drei haben Spaß am Start, ey.
Guckst du dir an.
Oh Gott.
Ähm.
Was wollte ich jetzt?
Ich wollte doch eine Sache machen.
Oh ja, strikt.
Früher hätte man gesagt, oh ja Max, strikt ist natt.
Kein Wunder, dass du die Gegner...
Die sind einfach alle übelst krass, die Leute.
Controller.
Ey, ich wollte jetzt ins Bett, ich wollte doch irgendwas machen vorher.
Nicht vergesse.
Was wollte ich denn machen?
Sag mal, was wollte ich denn machen?
Ach keine Ahnung.
Ah, moier weiter, ey.
Wahnsinn, ey.
Aber es kann mir keiner erzählen.
Der Trifthorz hat ja letztens ein Video drüber gemacht.
Ja, ja, bis morgen, morgen spielen wir dann.
Ähm, der Trifthorz hat ja ein Video gemacht.
Ähm, das hier, diese ganze Skill-based Matchmaking-Geschichte und so.
Das gibt's ja keinen Beweis für und so was.
Ja, das stimmt, natürlich gibt's keinen Beweis für.
Der endgültige Beweis wäre wirklich, wenn du lange Testreihen durchführst und so was.
Aber die Vermutung liegt halt wirklich nahe.
Wenn man sich anguckt, wie nice die ersten 3, 4, 5 Runden gewesen sind.
Die waren richtig cool, ja.
Ähm, und danach ist jetzt einfach nur...
In your face.
Ich mein, der Turn-on von dem Typ eben war schon...
Also, ich weiß nicht, wenn die alles so abgehen, dann hab ich da, glaub ich, keinen Spaß in dem Game.
Ich mein, ich bin echt kein Pro.
Vor allem mittlerweile bin ich da weit, weit von entfernt, ja.
Aber ich bin normalerweise in jedem...
Belegrad.
Aber in jedem Game, was ich ernsthaft gespielt hab, bin ich meistens instant irgendwie Top 10.
Nicht Top 10, äh, Top 10%.
Und wenn ich mir dann sowas wie Battlefield angucke, da bin ich, keine Ahnung, kleiner Top 1%.
Okay, das kann man jetzt nicht so direkt darauf übertragen.
Und natürlich kann ich jetzt lange erzählen, wie geil ich bin, obwohl ich in dem Spiel zacke.
Darf ich auch nicht vergessen, ich kann viel erzählen, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Aber so ultra-schwierige Matches, das erinnert mich...
Das erinnert mich ein bisschen an...
An, ähm, Face It, wo wir ein bisschen gespielt haben mit den Leuten damals.
Das war auch übelst das krasseste Getreiharde.
Aber da ging es ja wenigstens um Ranks, ja.
Das war okay.
Und ein bisschen an irgendwelche Overwatch-Grimms.
Das ist wirklich Wahnsinn.
Keine Ahnung, was da abgeht, ey.
Es können doch nicht nur die Top, die Top, keine Ahnung, die Top 0.0.0.1% der Welt spielen.
Das geht doch gar nicht.
Das geht doch statistisch gesehen schon gar nicht.
Egal, ich muss mir das noch mal ein bisschen in Ruhe angucken, aber schauen, wie man die Maps ordentlich spielt.
Weil ich habe selbst gemerkt, dass ich, dass ich sau oft, also es ist mir heute halt aufgefallen,
dass ich halt einfach sau oft in Teile der Maps renne, in der Teile der Map renne, wo nichts ist.
Und umgedreht in Teile der Map renne, wo was ist und da nicht vorsichtig genug reinlaufe.
Also das liegt definitiv auch an dem, wie ich spiele.
Aber es ist trotzdem krass, Try Hard.
Ist der Wahnsinn.
Ich glaube, ich habe noch kein Game gesehen, wo das so krass gewesen ist.
Warten wir mal morgen ab, wenn die Noobs reinkommen.
Schauen wir mal, wie das dann läuft.
Oder wisst ihr was?
Ey, wisst ihr, was wir mal machen müssten?
Das schreibe ich mir auf.
Wisst ihr, was wir morgen mal machen?
Wir reverse boosten morgen mal.
Und dann gucken wir uns das an, ob da was dran ist.
Ich werde mal morgen, ich weiß nicht, ob ich das on stream mache.
Aber ich werde morgen mal reverse boosten.
Und dann gucke ich mal, was passiert.
Und dann spielen wir mal übelst Try Hard.
Keine Ahnung, so 10, 15 Matches, so übertrieben angestrengt.
Und dann gucken wir mal, in welchem Abstand die Gegner krasser werden.
Ich werde einfach mal 30 Matches verlieren oder so.
Ich gehe einfach rein und mache dann irgendwie in your face ein Kreisel-Sniper oder so.
Krass.
Eax, falls du nachher noch spielst.
Wär cool, wenn du fertig bist, so mal deinen Eindruck im Discord schreiben kannst.
So irgendwie in 1, 2 Sätzen.
Würde mich echt mal interessieren.
Ich gucke ja morgen früh rein, wenn ich aufstehe.
Würde mich echt mal interessieren, was du für einen Eindruck hast nach den ersten paar Matches.
Weil du hast jetzt einen komplett neuen Account, der ist null vorbelastet.
Und ich weiß halt, dass du gut spielst.
Und das würde mich echt mal interessieren, wie sich das entwickelt.
Von anfänglich wahrscheinlich richtig nice Games zu in your face.
Na ja gut, ich glaube der Eax ist weg.
Matchmaking, 10 Matches.
Ja, das könnte hinkommen.
Die ersten Matches waren noch richtig cool.
Konnte leider nichts aufnehmen, weil ich Shadowplaning eingeschaltet habe.
Oder nicht ordentlich eingeschaltet habe am Anfang.
Na gut.
Leute wir sehen uns morgen.
Wahrscheinlich morgen.
Nee, ich spiele wahrscheinlich mit dem Eax paar Runden.
Ja.
Machts gut.
Bis morgen.
CU.
Tschüss.